what's your favorite part about the U.S
championships being held here in St
Louis well it's my first CS championship
and my favorite part is that it's so
long I really love playing this
old-fashioned long tournament and the
fact that is in St Louis is extremely
convenient for me because I live here
well I've only played one US
Championship that wasn't here I played
in 2008 that was my first one then 2009
I moved to St Louis and it's obviously
by comparison I could tell it was much
nicer and it's very professionally run
the price one's very good and uh yeah
one of my us Championship here once uh
felt amazing I love it it's cultural
it's a lot of strong players playing and
his chest and it's all together it's a
fantastic experience I'm just glad that
for the first time part of it
um well first of all I mean St Louis is
one of the nicest places I've been to in
the US and
it's kind of like been a routine for me
the last 10 years I've been coming every
year playing it's pretty much a second
home to me now yeah in a way it's um
there's very little pressure in an event
like that because you know I'm just
happy to to be here playing and uh you
know it's an enjoyable experience pretty
much no matter the result it's an
especially important tournament and this
year it's even longer than usual more
players so it feels like it'll be more
challenging but also more rewarding well
it's my first U.S Championship but uh
I really like St Louis I've spent a lot
of time here in the past few months and
my next results in St Louis
so it feels like not home but there's a
level of normalcy to playing Gear that I
don't get you know traveling around
Europe This is the closest thing I have
to home because I'm living in hotels so
the Chase Park Plaza is like my my
second home so it's nice to have
familiarity and of course just planned
or good conditions you know it's just
great to be in the atmosphere of St
Louis and you know the conditions here
are wonderful for the players and just
to be able to play all the top players
in the world is really unique for me and
it's something I'm really looking
forward to I generally just like the
atmosphere it feels since I've been here
so many times it feels like really
familiar I'm just ecstatic to be playing
at the U.S Championship like I didn't
really even expect to play this year but
I'm just really excited well I think in
general for me I've always enjoyed
um Forest Park a lot so anytime I come
to St Louis I make sure to to make as
many visits there as I can just explore
the nature and all it has to offer
especially now this time of year the
weather is great and yeah I look forward
to to venturing there again the
tournament just keeps getting stronger
every year which makes it harder for me
to try to win but
um that's probably probably the best
part is actually that I was just kept
getting stronger all the time I mean
back in 2015 there was like Hikaru and
maybe gotta monishook but back then like
I had a real chance of winning now I
still have a chance of winning but
there's there's lots of more competition
so it's forced me to try to improve
myself as well so I think that's that's
really great that tournament just keeps
getting better every year it's the
capital of Chess I would save them for
the world so it's amazing to play here
every single year well a couple of
things first of all I like the fact that
uh
um I live here so when I'm when I'm
playing here I get the support from from
my people from my family which is kind
of unusual in the Chess World because
you're always traveling and I also like
the fact that uh the atmosphere that
it's created here it's usually great and
uh that's that's also I think helpful
for chess like for example you are in
the middle of a tournament which is
normally very serious and you know it's
super competitive obviously and all that
but then you get to hang out with great
people like you know the organizers like
Joey and Tony and and Yasser and Rex
himself and and just for a few hours you
forget about the the tournament and you
have a good time and it's very friendly
and very nice and and that's I think one
of my favorite Parts well it really
feels like my home uh or basically my
second home so we're only an hour flight
away from Minnesota and I've been coming
here in and out for the last seven eight
eight years Years also I went to college
here 10 years ago also St Louis has been
hosting world-class tournaments the
singfield cup Etc
so when you come here you know you will
be challenged
[Music]